you uh
love movies i read this somewhere yeah
you mentioned blade runner as a favorite
number one of all time the final cut
that's my go-to
so you would say uh blade runner is the
greatest movie of all time it's one of
the greatest movies of all time
what's in the top nice top five uh
blade runner final cut this is the
original blade runner
and i used to own on tape the original
vhs cut yeah and uh
and i had the director's cut on dvd why
blade runner by the way
what as a kid i just thought it was so
cool there was something about
really spoke to me the whole cyberpunk
landscapes and uh you know this guy
chasing down rogue uh androids
replicants
and uh is it just the entire cyberpunk
uh universe robots as well no
it's i mean the cyberpunk universe is
part of it uh
on the on the surface i have a i've
always tended towards
dark subject matter uh like things that
are
of the dark so to speak are things that
i've always been gravitated towards
i think maybe part of it is that the
things that are darker
are more accepting and
more upfront with death
and perhaps i think that maybe that is
what was uh yeah somehow more honest
perhaps and
there's also the aspect of uh
rebelliousness usually like there was a
i was never one to want to just
do what somebody told me to do you know
um
i'm not sitting around trying to
always be such a radical individual that
i can't
take orders no in fact i'm more than
willing to take orders
from somebody that i feel is competent
and has merit and reason behind what
they're doing and makes like okay yeah
yeah
i'm 100 for not only what can i take
orders i will help
you achieve whatever it is if i think
it's worthwhile um
even at my own expense but uh
to get to that point is a rarity like
it's
not not a given and so you can even
imagine like being a grade school
teacher and this kid doesn't respect you
and he doesn't really think you're that
smart
they don't really appreciate that but um
so cyberpunk is number one what else
cyberpunk is kind of number one it's a
it's an environment i love but at the
same time conan the barbarian by john
millions is one of my
favorite films of all time uh
and you know that's such a pure
film in a way like the motivations are
pure they're very
easy to follow but not lacking in depth
you know it's not it's not just
explosions and and teal and orange it's
uh
it's it's more on the human condition
and i love it
and it's shot incredibly well it's got
an incredible soundtrack
yeah i [ __ ] love it but with blade
runner also in a deeper sense you know
again the human condition you know you
start seeing like what what is what is
being what is
being human uh you know how does this
relate to well if you can make it and
you can tell it what to do
at what point is it like you should or
you shouldn't
you know why do you get to determine
what's alive and what's not what's a
life
that should be allowed to live and what
isn't and
what would be the strain of being roy
batty
and seeing all these incredible moments
that with his passing will no longer
exist especially if he hasn't had a
chance to
put that flame into another torch so to
speak if he hasn't written them down if
he hasn't passed them down
to somebody else they're gone like tears
in the rain
like tears in the rain that scene is
incredible uh that i mean but
it's funny because those two universes
are very different according to the
and cyberpunk is there that makes me
curious about
what else might be in the list of
thoughts uh
well let me think i mean it's a pretty
do you like that that's a god there
is a type of universe no no i mean i'm
sure the god i've never actually even
watched
the whole godfather no but also like uh
was it a casino
goodfellas good phil is a good movie but
no that's not in my top
it's a good flick uh but it doesn't
really do it for me
uh i if people really want to get into
this a little more i did make a hundred
a list of a hundred hundred of my
favorite movies on my facebook fan page
nice
uh but uh do you remember like
oh yeah like blazing saddles is on there
ridge of the lost ark
um valhalla rising by nicholas from
winding refin
uh maniac by uh
william lustig it's a 1980
gnarly video nasty horror movie about a
serial killer uh
who murders women and scalps them
uh and it's gnarly as hell and very
brutal and very bleak
and very uh um
i mean it's the kind of thing that like
a lot of people would have a real hard
time watching
but uh one again i like things that are
dark
but two i thought the performances were
fantastic in this film and they really
got out
the i think what the underlying thing
was and it was you know it was a guy who
was
basically just like run amok by the
overbearing mother
union archetype and it she was
she imparted her insanity into him and
he
but yet there is this aspect you could
see of him wanting to try and actually
be able to be in
the world and have love and have
a feminine companionship
to go with with his masculine aspect
but he had no way of understanding how
to really make that happen
and he had a complete negative
connotation to the feminine
so his struggle with and there's a
little
part in the in the movie where he
somehow comes across this model
or something and they actually he starts
to feel like
maybe he might be able to actually have
a relationship with somebody
and it goes somewhere but uh yeah even
the elijah wood remake i felt was
really well done and captured most of
the essence of what the movie was about
but i still feel like the
original by william lustig uh is the
best
what's the greatest uh love
movie of all time greatest love movie of
all time it's like something more loves
i mean i suppose love underlies most of
these movies and especially
i mean hell takashi mikey's films are
all about
family of all things as bonkers as those
movies are
they the general theme is family almost
entirely
in all of his films uh yeah
there's very i mean even you can argue
later on yeah there's this
every love film of all time uh
that's interesting i mean is excalibur a
film about love
uh what's this called about king arthur
excalibur is about uh arthur becoming
king of the britons and his love of his
his country and his love of guinevere
but eventually yeah it becomes more of
about
um the the necessity for
the king to love to to
hold hold excalibur to stay to realize
that while if you're the king
you can love your wife and you can love
your best friend and they
may [ __ ] each other behind your back
and as they fall in love too but at the
end of the day you're responsible your
your love has to be to the
to the country and everyone else first
and not your own personal
uh wants which you know
well it made a much more interesting
story when you have uh carmen berenina
and and or oh oh what is that one it's
it's a german
opera but uh you know into horses and
slo-mo and
sword fights and an epic death scene
between
uh arthur and his his son okay now i
definitely have to watch it and evan
washington
embarrassed it's uh it is john borman's
second film in hollywood his first one
being uh point blank with lee marvin
which is also on top
one of the upper echelon movies on my
list
derived from a book by called
the outfit by
uh what is his name uh
i forget but darwin cook the comics
illustrator he did donald westlake wrote
so darwin cooked is does an amazing
comic book
send up of donald cook's novels and they
are [ __ ] incredible
so anyways but uh the point blank with
lee marvin
uh you know it's a man driven by
purpose revenge but also by like really
pure
motivations he wants his money he was he
was betrayed
and he wants his his cash because this
is what he agreed to do the thing for
and this is
which also is part of the reason why i
like no country for old men so much
which i felt was a great
great great movie even better book but
uh i remember talking to my friend and i
go you know
anton [ __ ] is the most pure human
being in that whole book
well that guy's the villain i go is he
evil
again he's the one he lies to no one he
does everything he says he will do
he always follows his word and on the
rare occasion he
he allows fate to make a decision as he
figures like well whatever all led us to
here
will will lead us one way or the other
and if we're at this crossroads what
how is there any better or worse way
than to do it over a coin flip
and so that whole scene where the guy is
going
well what am i putting up and he goes
everything you've been putting it up
every day of your life and that's true
everything we do
is as a as a decision as a calling is a
choice
and it toward and then it bumped me out
they
reduced the last interaction between
[ __ ] and
what's-his-face's wife when he finally
finds her
and she's like you don't have to do this
i mean she's he's like yes yes i do
this is the way it is you can think that
your life could have turned out any
sort of ways you could have done this
you could have done that but the reality
is this is the way your life is that's
the way it was always going to be
you know the fact that i'm here is the
end of it and that's that
yeah it's funny if you're honest this is
what dark movies reveal that the
villains
are the the purest of humans
and can teach us the most like profound
lessons and that's the certain
example of it
you